I gotta tell you and I really mean this
and I've told it to you before I'm a
really big fan of your work
I thank you thank you you know you know
how much I appreciate that hold on I'm
gonna I'm gonna put you guys
yeah I got it I got it I'd take him I
swear the value take your time with this
man I'll wait 45 minutes let me tell you
something I will I would I see the rest
of my time to the gentleman
he's one of the greats he's one of the
greats
he's unbelievable one of the grades yeah
I'm telling you yeah listen you can't
work the way Tom and and Chris work yeah
by the seat of your pants but not by the
seat of your pants that's exactly that's
exactly
um they know what they're doing
they have everything
up here for years ahead of time you know
what I mean but that allows them once we
get in there if someone like Briggs is
just it's written on the page that he's
just gonna go find track down Ethan Hunt
and bring him in it becomes more than
that if I bring something to it they
love that you know they allow that to
happen we spoke yesterday but what I
didn't get to ask you about was filming
at an unopened airport in Abu Dhabi
which is going to be one of the biggest
airports in the world yeah ah they
opened it up I mean again that's it
comes back to cruise
if he makes the call to a prince it
happens if he makes the call to a mayor
of a beautiful city like Rome I think
you know more amenable to letting us
scream through the streets in a Fiat I
really truly cannot believe what they
pulled off around this Fountain
specifically and since we're standing
here in Rome at the fountain maybe tell
the audience what they do because it's
crazy
uh what do you mean uh Cruz and
Macquarie or around the sequence that's
right around this Fountain oh oh yeah
yeah this is I mean first of all this is
one of my favorite places on the planet
the Spanish Steps because of Keats and
Shelley those are my two of my my
favorite poets so this has a real you
know history for me
and then we go get to go screaming right
up this street right here and I get to
do all the driving all my own stunt
driving and then if you can pan over to
Tarzan he was frightened as a child when
I was doing it he was so scared
we'll team the two of you up let's do it
we're always together so the thing about
this and I just she was just saying it
is that right here is one of the most
the big set pieces of the movie and what
taught what you guys do in Rome is crazy
oh you thought it was crazy because they
never let the city shut down like that
during the day and let you so talk a
little bit about filming the sequence
literally where you're standing I was
telling them about the driving and you
didn't know that I was going to be
driving I didn't know let me tell you
something we come to set right and I I
knew we had to you know drift follow
behind Tom and stuff like that and we're
we're doing the seated positions where
we have our dialogue and all of a sudden
they put cameras on on the hood and
they're like all right we're about to
start driving so I'm just on my phone
expecting a stunt guy to come in and
then he starts the car and I'm like
what
like what is going on they're like I'm
driving baby and he's driving almost
kill him I text my mom I'm like Mama
listen if something happens blame Shay
he was he was truly frightened I'm not
gonna lie like we when I say there was
no Stunt Driver that stepped in it
wasn't you know wait they allowed us to
go through it was a it was amazing
electric no it was like Hey honestly I
was terrified I won't lie I won't I
won't fabricate that but I was very very
impressed by what he did I'm still here
talking to you today which is amazing
that means he did a great job he still
loves me I still love him but what he
did in that car was incredible
how long early before filming began were
you practicing for the stunt
so I got the wrap up and I was trying to
finish truthfully
I I didn't do it a ton of driving
but I
am a good passionate driver and Wade
east east with our stunt taught me some
unbelievable stun stuff so
I'll just leave it to that yeah I'm
gonna leave it there and say gentlemen I
said it on camera yesterday I'll say it
again I love this movie it's going to be
a huge hit thank you for your time thank
you